I need to. Oh what happened.
uh, too hard to tell Welcome back everyone this
will be my full marvel hawkeye episode 2 video and
easter eggs there's a whole bunch of stuff to talk
about so we'll break it all down if you're brand
new to the channel i'm doing videos for all the
episodes so be sure to subscribe to get everything
i'm also doing a giveaway for disney plus
memberships all you have to do to enter just
be a subscriber and leave your favorite wtf moment
from the episode on the video careful for spoilers
if you have not seen the episode yet we'll be
talking about everything just starting at the
beginning we'll work our way through shot by
shot talking about easter eggs and wtf moments
starting with the episode title episode 2 was
titled hide and seek which is a reference to
the actual plot of the episode which is kate
bishop and hawkeye trying to hide and find the
ronin costume the plot starts to thicken a little
bit with the mystery of armond's death but like i
said during my episode 1 video i think they made
it pretty clear that it was probably swordmaster
who was behind it killing his uncle to gain his
inheritance using hawkeye's ronin sword which
he stole from the auction but the actual opening
scene starts right where episode 1 left off with
the cliffhanger of hawkeye ripping the mask off
kate bishop and grilling her on why she has the
ronin costume like what are you doing in this they
have a much quicker version of the hawkeye custom
intro with two arrows hitting the target just
to represent kate bishop and hawkeye teaming up
they reveal her apartment is above the pizza shop
that sells the pieces she was feeding to lucky the
pizza dog earlier in episode one and just like a
fangirl she starts grilling him on all his methods
and his moves while he jokes about her being a
little kid just calling her on her skills like
the world's greatest archer are you one of the
people that calls you the world's greatest archer
yes she says she inherited her apartment i
think that's a reference to her dad but she
doesn't really explain what the apartment was
used for before she started living there you
look around you notice the archery training setup
she has purple target for purple hawkeye colors
she asked him to sign her bow all just doing the
whole fangirl thing just going crazy oh my god
hawkeye is in my apartment like i said during my
episode 1 video she is like the world's greatest
hawkeye fangirl they revealed that he totally
knows everything about the tracksuits who they are
all from his time as ronan during that five
year time jump now he doesn't tell her that
he was ronin and i don't know if she's connected
the dots yet but during episode 1 kazi the clown
has that weird reaction when he sees her in
the hawkeye ronin costume like ronin oh my god
so i think the idea is that hawkeye almost killed
qazi in a lot of these other track suits during
that time period so that's why they hate him so
much in surprise surprise they tracked her back
to her apartment and her name is on the buzzer so
it's more of that record scratch kind of comedy
that they're using the die hard level of comedy
they have that funny action scene with the molotov
cocktails with them just going back and forth
like i said the track suits are basically meant
to be a bunch of incompetent fools kazi the clown
echo some of the other assassin characters in the
series are meant to be genuinely badass though
it's just the tracksuits that are supposed to
be really funny in really cool easter egg matt
fraction himself said that he was supposed to
have a cameo seen in the series because they're
basing it a lot in the plot of his comic book
as one of the track suits but when they were
getting ready to film his scenes he wasn't able
to travel because of the virus just during that
period of 2020 so there isn't any kind of matt
fraction cameo scene during the series but there
was supposed to be one they make a big joke about
taking off to get more adventure supplies but them
just being medical supplies from a regular bodega
that's meant to be a reference to the matt
fraction hawkeye run during that he spends
a lot of time reminding you that hawkeye has
no superpowers no mutant healing factor like
wolverine so every little cut every bruise every
broken bone every explosion he feels it and has
to treat it like you would treat any old wound so
as the hawkeye comic book run story goes on you
start to see him running around in more and more
bandages more and more cuts and bruises all over
his face and it's the same for kate bishop like
during the episode they show him treating her
wound like she shows up in each episode with more
and more little cuts and scrapes all over her face
just to show you that they're regular people like
they don't have super powers they also make a joke
about this when he explains why he's going deaf to
her like he kind of brushes it off like you know
i'm not really sure why i'm going deaf but they
give you that big montage of all these different
avengers movie scenes of huge explosions and
hinges getting his ass kicked all over the place
and if it wasn't clear him going deaf is actually
something that they did in the comics that being
more comic book accurate they just never really
addressed it during the marvel movies so far
she references the avengers tower and he reminds
us that tony sold it a few years ago during the
events of spider-man homecoming the marvel people
were also talking about that recently this is that
they love all the fantastic four baxter building
theories that people have but it's still going to
be a couple years before they officially reveal
what's going on with the old avengers tower i did
a bunch of videos about that when spider-man far
from home came out because during the scene where
they reveal the newly redesigned avengers tower
whoever bought it there are a lot of fantastic
four easter eggs in this scene so i'll add links
with that down in the description below they also
remind you that because this part of town they're
in midtown near hell's kitchen is also not too far
away from where the avengers tower used to be when
they go to her aunt's apartment i believe a lot
of the names here are names of comic book creators
and some of the members of the hawkeye series crew
anytime you see a giant list of names in a tv
series sometimes there'll be a couple easter eggs
and sometimes they'll just be the names of crew
members people behind the camera she uses pizza
to con her way into the building they're just
doing more lucky the pizza dog easter eggs raise
your hand if you also started to want more pizza
by the end of the episodes like hmm pizza actually
sounds pretty good right now like the hawkeye
series is just one secret giant ad for pizza
she shows up some of her lock picking skills and
we also find out that hawkeye has a cat allergy
which is actually brand new information is there
cats in here just cat hair when he goes back to
her apartment using the firefighter's uniform
the number 54 on his helmet is meant to be a
reference to avengers 54 which was a black knight
avengers crossover story where jarvis winds up
betraying the team allowing villains to get into
the avengers mansion we just met kit harrington's
black knight during the eternals movie and he
just got the ebony blade during the post-credits
scene just like the kang the conqueror easter egg
during episode 1 there are a lot of marvel phase 4
easter eggs during the hawkeye series it's weird
how much stuff this is connected to but i guess
that shouldn't be a surprise because it is a
marvel series everything is meant to be connected
they set up the whole plot with the larpers in the
cosplaying going on in central park for the next
day if it wasn't clear one of the firefighters
is a larper and stole the costume from the crime
scene when he goes back to kate bishop's aunt's
apartment the poster in the background here is
creature from the black galaxy it's meant to be
a fictional movie inside the mcu it's supposed to
be a spoof of the universal studios creature from
the black lagoon movie but the names on the poster
the actors here are also big comic book easter
eggs moira brandon was an extremely short-lived
character introduced during avengers west coast
number 100 hawkeye was a big character during
avengers west coast jeremy renner even said that
he would love to come back to lead a west coast
avengers team in a future marvel phase 4 project
making it sound like yelena belova will not be
successful in killing hawkeye during the hawkeye
series but in the comics moira brandon used to
own the house that the avengers bought and
turned into the west coast avengers mansion
the luke ballard name here is a reference to a
real life visual design artist for marvel studios
in the black galaxy itself is an actual location
in marvel comics it's a very bermuda triangle
like dangerous galaxy that winds up eating a lot
of spaceships it's also the place where ego the
living planet was created they make a bunch of
grinch references because obviously there's this
christmas theme that runs throughout the series
because it's the christmas holiday when this is
all happening but she calls him the grinch because
he's being so grumpy but then he says he's only
being like that because she stole his christmas
like the grinch did during the dr seuss story she
officially gives the dog the lucky the pizza dog
name saying she's thawing out his breakfast and
icing her wound at the same time they start
teasing out the development of their relationship
as mentor and student as he teaches her the
correct way to treat her forehead wound the next
day when he's sending his kids back home they make
another reference to sign language and him going
deaf just reminding you that he is going deaf and
also setting up the big echo twist later she is a
deaf character in the comics and they established
the whole premise him trying to clean up the ronin
mess and make it home in time for christmas i'll
be home in time for christmas famous last words
when the police start connecting the ronin costume
and kate bishop to armand's murder you notice that
there's another captain america rogers musical ad
on the tv there'll probably be even more of these
throughout the future episodes just seeing
the rogers musical ads all over the place
they pass by a bunch of avengers cosplayers
and she starts joking about him not having
good branding as a superhero or an avenger
but like i said he doesn't really care about
that kind of stuff he doesn't like recognition
he actively tries to avoid attention like that
he spent pretty much every single marvel movie
after the first avengers movie trying to retire
and not being able to like been trying to get
out of the game but they keep pulling me back in
she tries to give up a bit of a pep talk and
her whole argument about people post endgame
wanting more sincerity from their superheroes
not super grim dark or self-serious heroes you
could also take as a joke on the darker dc movies
you're so dark the eugenia from the dc universe
they also set up a big joke with his trick arrows
him lying saying that there are no trick arrows
when trick arrows are actually a huge part of
his character in the comics and during the matt
fraction hawkeye comic book run he's used them in
every single avengers movie here a couple of them
issues they don't focus a lot on them too much
like he'll just use them and they'll brush past
it really quickly then when kate bishop goes up
to her mother's office she immediately starts
grilling swordmaster about the murder and then
later during the family dinner just turning it
into this big cat and mouse game that she's
playing with him hawkeye goes larping in
central park to try and get the ronin costume back
from this firefighter and it's this whole battle
royale scenario they just play it for a lot of
comedy hawkeye agrees to take the l to get the
costume but they turn it into another separate
huge big thing joking that having to go through
all these steps to get the costume is somehow
worse than fighting thanos like i fought thanos
kate bishop does exactly what he told her not
to do starts texting him non-stop like she's
writing some kind of book when she jokes about
him being busy with his friends she is kind of
referencing the avengers but also then kind of
burns him saying that he doesn't have any real
friends which ouch because natasha was his best
friend and she's dead now like i said they will
continue to reference black widow several times
throughout all the episodes part of him working
with kate bishop will be him also using their
kind of relationship to deal with his grief over
the death of black widow true to his word the
firefighter brings him the ronin suit after he
goes down then he just puts it in a storage locker
in case he needs it later his wife references the
countdown clocked to christmas again saying five
days till christmas and references black widow
again by name then at their dinner kate bishop
winds up grilling swordmaster they verbally spar
back and forth at the dinner table foreshadowing
their actual sparring match with the swords later
the fight is also meant to show you swordmaster's
skills and how good he is at deception like it's
pretty clear these lying like we all kind of
know as the audience that he's lying to her
but it's when he disarms her so quickly so easily
and with such a flourish they think they're just
trying to show you how badass he is and hopefully
hype up a big sword match with hawkeye later in
the series like i said i think there's some
deep connection between him and hawkeye when
hawkeye was ronin during that five year time
jump but he has some vendetta against hawkeye
then big mistake kate bishop tells her mother
about her huge theory that jack killed his uncle
to get the inheritance using hawkeye's ronin sword
without considering that her mother might also be
connected to everything i think they're trying
to play that like it's some big twist like ah
shocking reveal i didn't realize that you are also
connected to all this shady stuff it's not really
until he offers her the monogram butterscotch
candy that she really freaks out like oh this
confirms all of my suspicions you are definitely
the person who murdered him and i feel like the
actor who's playing jack duquesne here swordmaster
did a really good job the reaction on his face
does not betray any emotion like he just kind of
shrugs like it's not clear whether or not he's on
to kate bishop whether he suspects her whether or
not he thinks that she knows that he's behind this
later hawkeye lets himself be captured by
the tracksuit bros so that he can find out
who's behind them like how high up does this go
he's just trying to find out who their boss is
one of them says she wants him alive hawkeye alive
that turns out to be echo who in the comics works
for kingpin so it just keeps going up like echo
is not the end of this she is not the person at
the top of the food chain here when kate bishop is
trying to track him down the login for her phone
app 11 2012 seems like an avengers reference and a
reference to the matt fraction hawkeye run because
the hawkeye run started in 2012 the same year
2012 that the avengers battle of new york also
took place the place where the track suits take
him that warehouse is in hell's kitchen starting
to bump up against more daredevil easter eggs and
references but when they start complaining about
how hard it was for them to find a spare warehouse
to interrogate him in because everything's being
converted to lofts nowadays that's another
reference to the map fraction hawkeye run
during that the difference in the story was
the tracksuits controlled the building where
hawkeye rented an apartment and they're trying to
evict all the elderly tenants so they can convert
the building into more expensive real estate in
hawkeye is trying to stop them from doing that
just as they reference kate bishop in the ronin
costume she crashes through the skylight like i
said more comedic action it's a big parody
of a superhero landing look at it superhero
landing they even give her this really grand
sounding superhero landing music as she splats
on the ground then when they reveal echo for the
first time like her debut scene here the red light
is meant to be a reference to daredevil she's from
the daredevil comics she was raised by kingpin
to be an assassin she is deaf which is why she's
touching the speakers when they play the music and
why she motions to the tracksuit bro to get out
of the room and in the comics the reason why she's
called echo is because her ability is to copy
people's moves on the fly kind of like taskmaster
and is even badass enough to beat daredevil in
a one-on-one fight then like i said the new end
credits like all these graphics made to look like
the matte fraction hawkeye comic book art this is
all plot from upcoming episodes with them fighting
the tracksuits the car everything so it's almost
like they're giving you a teaser for episode 3
in comic book form over the credits but obviously
they'll get into more of echo's character and her
backstory during episode three next week and like
i said each episode will air one per week like
normal from now on so my full hawkeye episode
3 video will post next wednesday if you spotted
any other big easter eggs in the episode that i
didn't talk about during the video just write them
below in the comments i think we'll start seeing
some more daredevil and kingpin easter eggs as
we get more of echo's character they are doing
a full spin-off series with echo they already
announced it during that marvel disney plus
day and all the trailers supposedly that series is
supposed to feel like a daredevil season four like
they're bringing back all the daredevil netflix
characters and actors and it'll be kind of like
they're just continuing on in their storyline
i'm not really expecting to see a lot of yelena
belova easter eggs or even her showing up till
the later episodes i'll name a giveaway winner
when i post my next big marvel video everyone
click here for my full hawkeye episode 1 video
and click here for my brand new spider-man no
way home video with venom and morbius easter eggs
thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and i'll see you guys in the next one!